before we say goodbye let's play a quick  round of truth or dare  [Applause]  all right denisha hi sparkles hi  hi  all right what's it gonna be a truth or  a dare there all right we're down for  just about anything  sure uh-huh yeah i think so have you met  me in honor of colorful uh hour i dare  you two to silly stream each other  just silly string each other  silly straight yes we do are you kidding  me where is it oh  thank you asia  thank you what color you want  we're gonna do it  okay  are you ready drew county three two one  [Applause]  thank you  [Applause]  thank you so much for having us do that  thank you you spend your time with us we  make the show for you thank you  [Music]  you